have I mentioned that Joe is a murderer
and he should not be trusted have I
mentioned that it's pretty common for
people to hate their jobs but did you
know that these actors playing some of
our most beloved characters in pop
culture Hawkeye James Bond and Serena
Vander Woodsen absolutely hated them I
have no idea what the film is going to
look like in the Marvel Universe have
zero clue number one this one doesn't
surprise us too much we're actually
pretty glad Penn Badgley isn't a fan of
use Joe Goldberg though he plays the
role to Perfection the writers tried to
write Joe as someone audiences would
somewhat relate to and in turn feel
conflicted about but overall Joe has
done some pretty gnarly things
throughout the show's running okay now
don't look so scared take a breath
Penn Badgley thinks Joe shouldn't be
empathized with as he's capable of a lot
of dark things what he does is he takes
the tropes that we've seen in romantic
comedies and it totally subverts them by
actually following them closely and he
comes to this really kind of terrifying
conclusion number two Sean Connery
wasn't the only actor who hated playing
James Bond when Daniel Craig took over
for Pierce Brosnan people were wondering
whether he could pull off the role or
not but after four consecutive hits
nobody wondered anymore even though the
films were a huge success amassing over
800 million in the box office Daniel
Craig is not interested in stepping back
into those shoes again I'm over it at
the moment we're done all I want to do
is move on if I did another Bond movie
it would only be for the money number
three we're talking about her role as
Harley Quinn something tells me a whole
lot of people are about to die Margot
Robbie first landed the role in the 2016
film Suicide Squad and continued on to
film birds of of prey in 2020 despite
margot's incredible performance in both
films it's hard to please die hard comic
book fans she received tons of criticism
for her portrayal of the iconic
character and she would often have
moments of panic on set because of it
I'm like oh God they're gonna hate it
there are just so many people to please
and you can't ever make everyone happy
number 4. Kirsten Dunst had a lot of
issues filling the big shoes of Mary
Jane Watson the production team really
wanted her to do some things that she
was pretty uncomfortable with even to
the point of trying to coerce her to
change her teeth they really pushed for
her to do this bungee jumping scene she
even tried it once it didn't go well I
was like you should have shot that
because I'm never doing that again I was
like that's never happening I was
terrifying overall it seems like they
demanded a lot from her and she just
wasn't with it one of The Producers
tried to subtly coerce me into changing
my teeth into those perfect Barbie doll
teeth I was like nope I'm not doing that
either number 5. Jeremy Rena was
absolutely fed up with Hawkeye when he
originally signed on he thought he was
going to get to dig deep into the
complexity of the character but he found
the journey to be pretty underwhelming
he was even at the point where he was
asking for the character to be written
off he attributed his performance to
that of a Mindless zombie there's not a
lot of backstory or understanding we can
really tell about who Clint Barton is or
Hawkeye and is he working for Shield or
not there's a lot of unanswered
questions even for me number six this
list wouldn't be complete without
talking about Edward Cullen everyone
knows Robert Pattinson isn't a fan of
the sparkly vampire though his
performance definitely made an impact on
pop culture he couldn't even sit through
the premiere he ran out of the theater
saying he just couldn't handle it he
said so many negative things about the
franchise we couldn't possibly list them
all it's a lot of stuff in the Twilight
World it doesn't make any sense when an
interviewer asked him if he had taken
anything from the set of the last movie
his response was my dignity
number seven everyone's favorite upper
east cider Serena Vander Woodson though
ironically Blake Lively wouldn't
consider herself a Serena fan she
struggled with playing the role
sometimes due to the questionable
decisions Serena would make people loved
it but it always felt a little
personally compromising you want to be
putting a better message out there the
taxing role might have also contributed
to the three-year Hiatus she took from
acting right afterwards she ended up
launching a lifestyle website and
spending time with her family only to
pick up acting again in 2015 with age of
Adeline number eight we're talking about
her character Marnie Michaels from the
HBO series Girls Allison Williams was
not a fan of Marnie and all of the
questionable decisions she made
throughout the show's run she finds her
completely unrelatable and most of the
time pretty annoying Marnie would drive
me crazy if we were friends in real life
but I have to put that out of my head in
order to play her number nine we weren't
too surprised to find out Miley Cyrus
didn't love her Alter Ego Hannah Montana
Miley fans know just how hard she worked
to separate herself from the Disney icon
she says that working on the set gave
her unrealistic expectations of beauty
and played a hand in the inevitable body
dysmorphia she struggled with I had been
made pretty every day for so long and
then when I wasn't on that show it was
like who am I number 10. Macaulay Culkin
is not a fan of Kevin McAllister or his
iconic Home Alone face he still to this
day gets stopped on the street by fans
asking him to do the face considering he
was nine years old when he filmed the
movie it's no surprise that he's not
amused he explains I can't watch it the
same way other people do and when people
ask to watch the movie with him he
describes it as flattering and creepy
number 11. probably one of the only
people who hated Han Solo Harrison Ford
literally begged the Creator George
Lucas to end his character after the
third film because he was fed up with
playing him and thought it would give
him some depth I did think the character
itself was relatively thin I would have
liked to see some complication for the
character the only reason he kept coming
back was because of how successful Star
Wars was so I was happy to come back and
play Han Solo again
and again but that was enough number 12.
Jason played Marshall Erickson on How I
Met Your Mother for eight years that was
part of the problem though Jason Siegel
is an incredible comedic actor he was
getting tired of Marshall's world he
thought the jokes were getting stale and
the story lines were getting predictable
also playing the same character for so
long started to weigh on his confidence
in playing other roles I didn't know if
I was a good enough actor to do it and I
kind of walked through the are you a con
man in this business kind of fear number
13. Sarah Michelle Geller hated playing
Buffy in the show's sixth season real
Buffy fans know that's when the show
took a majorly Dark Turn Sarah Michelle
Geller agrees Buffy engages in a
questionable relationship with the
soulless vampire Spike that inevitably
takes a turn into abusive territory
Geller who arguably knows Buffy better
than anyone didn't agree with her
actions that season I've always said
that season 6 was not my favorite I felt
it portrayed who she was number 14 this
Two and a Half Men star wasn't always a
fan of Jake Harper particularly after
joining a Seventh-Day Adventist Church
and converting to that religion he
couldn't find it in him to continue to
support the show he made a pretty bold
statement to People magazine I'm on Two
and a Half Men and I don't want to be on
it please stop watching it please stop
filling your head with filth number 15.
Catherine Heigl starred in one of the
most successful longest running TV shows
Gray's Anatomy though she won a prime
time Emmy in 2007 for best supporting
actress in a drama series she still
worked very hard to separate herself
from her character Izzy and the show as
a whole she even went as far as to
refuse her work for consideration of
another award the following year she
didn't think the material she had to
work with deserved an award
unsurprisingly in 2010 she ended up
leaving the show after a lot of
speculation around the topic that same
year she told USA Today I felt she was
an admirable woman who certainly made
mistakes but I was starting to not like
her and that bothered me
do you have any idea how much these
actors hated their own characters we can
definitely understand why for many of
them which character on this list is
your favorite